i am trying to be intentionally out of
touch
in the same way that i intentionally
avoid the news
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on
well
yeah well sam
yeah
you're my first million has become
my first hundred thousand
yeah your first
my last million
yeah on a good day what um
you took something out of the milk road
i texted you this but you didn't reply
you so in the milk road my favorite part
was you had what was the starting amount
a million or 500 or what was it
you had your portfolio it was actually a
little bit less it was 950 000. so 950
000 portfolio and every day you would
say what it's at compared to
what it was you took it out what's it at
now correct
why'd you take it out uh i don't even
want to look we took out the prices
today because uh or what do we do we
today we did a little different thing so
the crypto prices crashed over the
weekend
and so we were like okay people are
definitely going to want to know like
what's happening
happening all that stuff so
no not saturday uh monday we sent it
today um no you sent a weekend
weekend version
yeah that was just a different that was
just like a special edition yeah that
was that was nothing um today we sent
like uh
why is crypto crashing the weekend one
was about jack dorsey because jack
dorsey announced something called web5
and we were like which is hilarious it's
just like a hilarious thing because it's
like web
people are debating it
is even a thing and like he just skipped
web 4 and went straight to web 5 and
like you know people like what the hell
is this so we explained what the hell is
this that's what the weekend one was
but today
uh crypto's down like 20 or something
crazy um like if the room is is like i
don't know thousand dollars or something
like that right now
um
so yeah dude it's brutal uh the million
dollar portfolio we basically started
this right when i started the milk road
i was like what will be entertaining to
get people hooked to subscribe and i was
like oh i know i'll put up a million
dollars
and i'll say
watch i will publicly invest this money
and let's try to turn it into 10 million
it became a mission turning 1 million
into 10 million through crypto investing
and to be honest we didn't even do that
much uh we didn't even make very many
moves like it just started with a
million dollars worth of eth
and i think we made like two investments
maybe uh since then just because i've
been busy with the milk like building
the milk road and like the podcast and
my other business and stuff like that
it's not like i've been super active
but um eth is down like 66 and all of
crypto is down like that or worse and so
uh the portfolio is brutal it's like you
know a million dollars is currently
250 or 300 thousand dollars is my guess
uh based on where we're at
where's your head at are you freaking
out or are you still calm like you
always are
uh i'm still calm yeah so so this is
it's a funny little like story i guess
um
i don't know why i said it's funny
there's actually no humor at all in it
it's interesting how how i feel about it
um
ben flew in so ben flew in last night
not producer ben business partner ben so
business partner ben flies in last night
where he's gonna be here for the week
we're gonna like work on a bunch of
stuff and like basically like you know
from the time he took off the time he
landed like our whole business has
changed and what has changed is
basically like
well aside from our own personal
net worths uh you know going down
and the milk road public portfolio going
down
like we have just entered uh like the
whole economy has entered a recession
and crypto has entered for sure like a
big downswing bear market crash whatever
you want to call it
and it's good it's not going to like
just bounce right back and all is going
to be like fun and dandy again like
if you think about this time last year
i'm not this time last year but let's
say like six to 12 months ago
it felt like
money was raining from the skies like
you know
i i invested in a bunch of tech stocks
everything was up every day everything
was up zoom is tripled in price and
amazon is up because everybody's
ordering all their [__] online and like
every company that we invested in
private startup was like raising money
at crazy valuations
and literally like there's a phrase of
money raining on fools money was raining
on fools and like nfts were selling you
know nfts were selling for ridiculous
prices
and it's so crazy that like you know on
a dime
uh it feels like the whole world has
changed and everybody's mindset
mentality has also changed which is that
like now it feels almost impossible to
make money it's like well where do i go
make money this stock market is down
brutally um crypto is crashed uh every
business is now laying off people or
freezing hiring
um on top of that you know at companies
are cutting their budgets and ad spend
so if you're if your business relied on
ads you know that's getting cut and so
now you know our money was raining
and now money's being drained from from
smart people too
you're seeing advertisers run i tweeted
out like what's going on in the ad world
because i'm not in it anymore you're
seeing it go away
i'm not this fast but yeah like you know
the first uh shooter drop was like kind
of like
consumer
brands like d2c brands and whatnot
they were the first i would say the last
three months to start like reducing
spending whereas before it was like how
do i spend more
and then there was like companies that
are like well it's hard to have a big ad
budget when you're laying off a bunch of
people so there now that they went into
hiring freezes or layoffs their ad
budgets are certainly tightening up we
don't see it this month like this
month's an all-time high and ad revenue
but like
i'm sure in the next three months that
ad budgets are going to constrict they'd
be crazy not to
um in our ecommerce business we see
sales
like this month is good but you could
see the tightening happening where it's
like
you know people just are you know
they're not getting stemi checks that
they can go spend on you know you know
um electronics and toys and and clothes
and and all this good stuff
and so
consumers are start slowing down their
their spending and so it's like and all
these things are interlinked right like
because when the consumer spends less
the business makes less money then it
has less money to hire less money to
advertise and then the platforms get
less revenue and then they do the same
thing and it's all just interconnected
right so
this is interesting to me because
i have not lived through a bear market
as a
founder or
investor
right like 2008 i was a
sophomore in college or something like
that right like i don't know you would
probably say you're like a yeah freshman
or sophomore in college i graduated i
graduated high school in 08 so basically
this is our first time as like money
earning professionals that we've
experienced anything like this yeah
dude it is so i'll give you kind of my
my mentality because you said like are
you freaking out my mentality was like
definitely i've had thoughts of like oh
[__]
oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] but then i sort
of like well
the thought can arise but i'm not like
consumed by it like i definitely had
like a day where i was like kept
checking prices kept doom-scrolling
twitter but like i don't know
if i pride myself on like you know my
mental fitness that's like well this is
the time to be fit it's like when stuff
that's hard happens this is the time to
use all those tools you've been building
up all those muscles you've been
building about like
seeing things in a way that actually
serves you and so for me i'm like
immediately i'll show you this thing
so ben flies in and last night at
midnight we're basically he was sitting
in my office and we we wrote this thing
at the top i don't know if you can see
this is like unfocused but it says like
how a loser's brain would work right now
lose your brain it's like lose your
brain says this we all like you know
like rich dad poor dad yeah in my head i
have this thing called lose your brain
winter brain it's like a loser's brain
will bring these thoughts up and bring
its attention to these things and a
winner's brain will have these like so
we basically wrote down all the scary
thoughts it's like
uh you know and so i was like ben just
rattle them off so i'll read you some of
these if you're interested but like uh
well all right but we did this exercise
in order to reframe our thinking
everything that i think about right now
and i've been i'm calm about it because
i i've alwa i'm you everyone gives me a
hard time that i'm conservative and it's
kind of working out right now but even
still i'm down
a huge amount um
and
my fear is always rooted in like i'm
gonna run out i'm like i'm i'm homeless
do you have those fears of like i'm i'm
gonna run out
no
um because if i actu if i asked you do
you actually think you're gonna run out
no but there's no way you sampler think
you're gonna go broke
which is the combination of
you got a lot of money still and
secondly
you always have like your core skill is
the ability to make and sell products
that people are going to want
well i'm not saying how do you ever just
i'm not saying it's logical i'm saying
like it's like my fear of flying i
understand that like i'm i'm far more
likely to fall off like a set of stairs
or to get hit in the car going to the
plane but i'm still like it's such a
deep-rooted
issue and i think it's actually deep
rooted in a lot of people of like i just
[__] i worked
so long for this thing and it's gonna
run out joseph kennedy the jfk's dad i
read his biography he was like the
eighth or ninth richest person in
america uh when he was alive and i think
he was worth a hundred million dollars
and he said i would give away half of my
money now if it meant i would be guarant
yeah i get i would be guaranteed to have
the other half forever and grow at a
very conservative but consistent rate
because he was like i'm just so afraid
of losing everything that i worked for
and that lost adversion is often like
that
it's like way harder would you do that
by the way would you take that trade
no no i wouldn't but me uh
no no
i i think that the world so he said that
probably in 1920 i think like i think
that i still am bullish on america and i
still think that over the next 100 years
like i'm gonna it's gonna average seven
or eight percent a year and i'll be okay
so i'm i'm okay with no i wouldn't do it
i still think and everyone talks about
america like um like oh like uh empire's
only last 250 years and we're we're
there and in my head i'm like but
do you think that we're gonna go to zero
like england like has been around for
two thousand years and they're not
number one or number two but like being
number seven is pretty good too do you
know what i mean and so whatever people
talk about like america's gonna collapse
i'm like well like wait
they still got like a dude standing in
front of a building all day like a
statue you can go take pictures of them
right so like life can't be that bad
there they got the guy with a fuzzy
black hat on
yeah like it's not that bad like i
wouldn't mind being germany or france
and like they they like were the best
for 2000 years and now they're not
number one on number two but like you
know i'll be the red sox it's okay like
it's not a big deal so anyway i'm pretty
like long-term bullish on america so no
i wouldn't give away half are italians
italians still eating pasta are the
spain the spaniards still taking naps in
the middle of the day like yeah you
don't need to be number one to live a
very sweet life
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like so it's not
like i'm i'm happy
so i want to describe because i think
this is the main topic right like i had
a bunch of like you know random ideas
and stuff like that we can get to those
but i do think the main topic is
probably where most people are at is
our audience is i would say heavily
entrepreneurial
and or work in tech if you let's just go
through both scenarios if you work in
tech
you're likely um you know have a lot of
your net worth invested in either the
stock of the company that you're being
paid in
or you
um you know you might be invested in the
mark crypto the crypto markets or the
stock markets and um
most likely you are you've taken a bath
of like you know something between 30
and 60
of your net worth in like the span of
five months has evaporated and like
whatever plan you had for buying a house
you know you're like oh wait you know
the
my money is sort of you know a lot of my
money is gone and the interest rate has
gone up and like you know or like you
know i wanted to have that kid another
kid and like now i need to like think
twice before i do that and like [__]
i've been ordering groceries like three
days you know
ordering door dash three days a week
like
do i really need to pay like you know 32
for you know a burrito and chips like
you know you start to reassess a bunch
of things in your life
um especially because the last 10 years
like if you're around our age we're like
you know kind of like early 30s like all
you've seen since you graduated was
numbers go up and so it's kind of
jarring to suddenly see
numbers go down at least that's my
perspective do you think i accurately
like labeled one part of our audience
yeah in particular the last uh two years
like it's been like up up up up up like
crazy yes that and that that is our
audience
and then you have business owners who
are like great this thing i've been you
know working so hard at every day for
the last x years
like here's the here's the good news uh
long silence okay here's the bad news
now your valuation is like cut in half
your customers are likely going to you
know start tightening up and paying you
less money um you're probably going to
have to do some layoffs trimming
somewhere in your business in your cost
structure
and like there's a
i don't know 30 to 40 percent chance you
go out of business in the next year and
a half
on top of whatever your normal risk of
going out of business was and so like
great you know you have risk of going to
zero and so that's a kind of stressful
thought and so on both sides you have
this kind of stressful kind of
depressing thought
and uh i would say
and if you're an investor you know all
the same thoughts you know times two so
where does that leave you you know
you're either in a puddle of despair
or you're gonna be like okay i need to
kind of like giddy up and rea and i have
to realize the environment has changed
and if that changed what needs to change
in my world and so i think there's like
a pretty healthy exercise to go down of
like what needs to change in my world uh
and i would say like that's the
productive conversation
so it's not enough to just be like i'm
just gonna close my eyes and think happy
thoughts and be positive it's like
well
i need to
be realistic a lot of shit's changed i
probably need to change with it but also
like
do i want to sit here and feel depressed
or hopeless no and so therefore i gotta
like
you might have that thought of like i
could lose it all or this will go to
zero or like all my hard work is gone or
like whatever all those thoughts but in
my mind it's like
i need to reprogram my brain to operate
in this new world and i need to like
basically i need to like consciously
reprogram my brain so that i have well
what i'm
my point is i do believe
like or i do have that fear of it's all
going to go away and my reaction is not
quit my or my reaction isn't even spend
less my reaction is yeah it might go all
the way it might go away let's get after
it like let's go get more or let's go
you you know like it to me it's a very
stressful period but it's a period it's
not actually stressful when i actually
like logically think about it i'm like
it's not that big a deal but it is a i
think that
whenever i look back at the [__] that
i've made that's been successful it
typically is when there's not a lot of
alternatives um and it's like oh man
this needs to work
so
right i do my best work when when back
against the wall that's a that's a one
thing that a lot of people believe and
that's a belief that can serve you well
when things get hard
so it is stressful but
uh you
you
i i think i said this a while ago i go
you're
i think i'm more likely to be like a
slow and steady like success whereas
you're more likely to become a
billionaire in like five years or lose
it all and so
because you take you take
well you take a lot of risk or both
you'll become a billionaire then you
take way more your risk on um
so that's why i'm interested in hearing
your perspective on this right now
because you're like
you're you're all in on a couple things
that that just so happen are getting hit
the worst
so what would be fun to talk about what
would be interesting to talk about like
you know we can go into like why we
think it's happening we can go into like
what are you going to do about it we can
go different well i don't actually man
like where do you want to go i don't
want to go into why it's happening and i
was thinking about this we're in this
text group with all those guys and
they're all like it's just a bunch of
like
supposedly smart people uh no they
actually are smart but like
they uh
they're
what's crazy is that like
america has been around for
hundreds of years
uh capitalism has been around for
thousands of years and yet the smartest
people don't agree on the cause or the
solution and they can't predict what
happens and that's kind of interesting
to me because
at your business at a business like you
have a pipeline and you have a funnel
and when you build a good business
you're like all right there's a 90
chance that blank is gonna happen and i
understand that business
america is kind of like a business just
with 330 million people and like a weird
gover a weird corporate structure where
like you can't really like do whatever
you got to get all these checks and
balances and all this [__] done but
isn't it kind of fascinating that we
still don't entirely understand the
cause or the solution to a lot of these
different
problems that's always been very
unsatisfying it's like
stock market goes up or down
then there's like this race to make up
the cause
and it's like um okay so you're saying
every time that happens this will happen
no okay so you're saying that you could
have foreseen this well it's like and
what it is is like you know sort of this
backwards application of narratives and
it's not that there was no cause or
there is no true narrative it's just
that
it's not easy or clear to see what is
the true cause and what are the true
narratives amongst the many possible
explanations and reasonings you could
have right like did it rain today
because i did this dance or did it rain
today because you know the clouds have
you know heavy whatever precipitation
and why do they have that well because
of the changes in weather and whatever
else like you know it's very it's very
hard to separate the people who think
things are happening because they did
the they think it's raining because they
did a funny dance
it's just that we can predict certain
human behavior
relatively reliably um like you know the
whole padlocks dog thing like i i know
that if i do this this and this most of
the time a creature is going to react by
doing x y and z and i was and it just
kind of has always baffled me i'm like
well why can't we just take all this
input and put it together and figure out
what the solution or what the cause is
and that's always baffled me and it also
freaks me out that uh
so many people who i view as smart say
opposite things do you follow a zero
hedge on twitter
yeah so zero hedge is like this pretty
hardcore i don't know if it's like
libert libertarian's the best way to
describe it but like they're pretty much
always like doom and gloom and every
article is written by the guy from fight
club what's his name tyler durden tyler
durden yeah and every article is written
uh by that guy uh
and their twitter profile
they only tweet in caps
every tweet is a is it caps lock and
they
they tweet the scariest stuff
all the time and it's incredibly easy to
believe and trust for some reason
because i don't know what it is about
emotion that i just automatically assume
that the worst is actually the truth
and
i i've had it like unfollow that did you
have your do you follow that handle
yeah for sure and i i would not unfollow
it but i i totally get what you mean
which is that like
um if you follow zero hedge you're just
like wow
all of the big
people in charge are sort of idiots and
all of the stuff that's going up is you
know overvalued and overinflated and
over everything
and like you know no matter how bad it
is
it could get worse don't think that this
is the end of the pain right and and
that you know like people have said this
about like you know people who predict
crashes and recessions it's sort of like
this guy's predicted you know a
recession 13 out of the last three times
it's happened and it's like you know if
you're every year you predict a crash
you know um
you'll be seen as a genius because you
predict it for three straight years like
then it happens like well you weren't
wrong you were just a little early
and then like you know
all those years where things are going
up um
you know you're again you're just sort
of like you're just early and so it kind
of pays
uh somebody said this the other day like
i would say in general like it in a bear
market you know it pays to be a
pessimist and in a bull market it sort
of uh pays to be an optimist and
somebody who's always a pessimist or
somebody's always an optimist is not
going to have like long-term success the
ability to shift gears between like
optimism and pessimism and knowing when
to do what is a like highly underrated
trait that uh very few people have let
me tell you what i'm doing with the i
don't exactly have a business i don't
really have like a business business but
i have a a a small version of that that
might become a proper business let me
tell you what i'm doing and then you
tell me what you're going to do but
basically my reasoning and keep in mind
i'm like
i feel so stupid when it comes to this
finance and economy stuff i don't know i
really don't don't understand anything
but my belief is basically like
well
now's the bottom and i actually
discovered this with the hustle where i
was like i was creating something that
people kind of dismissed or thought it
couldn't work but then it takes like
four five six years to get to like uh a
substantial business and by that point
people took it seriously and i was the
biggest and the best and therefore could
get acquired or was making a lot of the
revenue so with my the thing i'm working
on now my my logic is well now is the
time to work really really hard and it
might suck for one or two or three years
but when things start changing a little
bit that's actually around the time
where i'm gonna have a team i'm gonna
have process i'll have systems i'll have
product market fit and then we can
accelerate really hard then because
we've already done the hard work during
the hard times is that is that kind of
how you're looking at it too a little
bit
yeah definitely i think that's um that's
definitely the case so what what i said
was i said kind of three things to
myself
i said number one
this is a good chance to remember what i
truly believe it's like and this is like
first i needed to calm my nerves because
if i'm in a
sort of fight or flight if i'm in a
state of like panic anxiety and stress i
already know my decision making is not
very good my decision making is at best
rushed
and at worst it's you know like
operating from a place of fear and
therefore all i'm trying to do is like
um you know like minimize pain and never
like get any any advantage out of it
just like minimize the amount of
disadvantage i'm having in the short
term
and so our my first step for me is get
out of a fight-or-flight mindset and so
that's where i first just checked myself
i'm like
well what do i really believe i truly
believe this in the bottom of my heart i
don't mean this in an arrogant way but i
truly believe that like
if i look at my life over like a 10 to
20 year period from here right i'm in my
early 30s so by the time i'm 40 or 50
like i think i'm gonna have more money
than i'll ever know what to do with to
me that's like the spoiler of my life
it's like if i flip to the end of the
book i'm like oh it ends happily ever
after yeah like i truly believe that i
truly believe that like i'm just gonna
keep doing business projects i'm gonna
keep investing in things and like on the
whole i'm gonna end up so far ahead even
if any individual investment or any
individual business project doesn't work
out in a 10 to 20 year period that when
i check the score at the end of the game
like i'm gonna be ahead i'm gonna have
more money than i know what to do within
my personal life i truly believe that
about myself so if i knew that was the
ending
there's no real reason to panic like if
i know that's what the score is at the
end of the fourth quarter then like it
doesn't really matter what happens in
the first quarter like i should i should
for sure be playing and doing my best
but like it doesn't matter if i fall
behind or if i lose a little bit money
here if the score doesn't go my way for
this next 12 to 18 months that's okay so
that that it's like i gotta remember do
i believe that or not all right i do
believe that then she'll first chill the
[__] out okay that's that's like wait
wait wait let me let me tell you
something though really quick
to let me be the huge pessimist here um
i believe that that is true about you as
well
i believe that that is true about a
bunch of people who we know but here's
the thing that i think about all the
time it's like i don't want to be
i don't want to have more money than i
know what to do with when i'm 70. i want
to [__] it now when i'm young and i can
experience all this crazy stuff and like
enjoy life i don't want it then i want
it now by by then i don't care like i
i'm okay with having way less i want it
today i want the freedom now when i'm
healthy and can go do whatever i want
that's why i freak out like
i'm with you but it's sooner the better
it's not now or never so sooner the
better is very different than now or
never and so okay we got a sooner than
better mindset so we're going to take a
bunch of shots we'll take a bunch of
action now to increase the odds that it
comes sooner rather than later the
second thing is
does it matter did my day-to-day
actually change
because my stock portfolio my crypto
portfolio my net worth changed right
like your net worth it's not a figment
of your imagination but it's sort of
like a figment of your uh like ego or
sort of like a figment of your like
perceived sense of safety and so like in
reality
the stock market go down the crypto
market go down it doesn't actually
change my like day-to-day lifestyle or
comfort based on where i'm at for some
people it's going to change that but for
me it's not going to change that so that
also helps take the edge off which
allows me to think with a clear head
then i start thinking alright you're not
changing you're not changing your
spending pattern
oh like in a small way but nothing that
like
my happiness on a day-to-day level
doesn't change whether i you know like
uh like
you know have a chef or not you know
like oh cool it's cooking season then
right okay cool i'm buying i'm going to
i went to trader joe's yesterday instead
of whole foods yeah i shift some i shift
some small decisions but like that's
cool trader joe's is sick like you know
who cares like those sorts of things
don't actually like sway how i feel wait
i was gonna get another car did you
actually do that i guess i'll hold off
on that
you're doing trader joe's trader joe's
yeah like literally literally yeah like
but again i like traditions this is not
a big problem for me because i drove
four extra blocks and went to the trader
joe's um you know like
cool so so you know and again not
everybody is fortunate we're like these
are like their situations i get that
uh but like i'd like to believe that in
general my my day-to-day like kind of
happiness quotient is not
so so weak that it's like dependent on
these like
material or like you know like frivolous
things it's like you know sometimes i
get stuck in traffic well guess what i
don't know radio baby it's a concert
right like a big ass honey crisp apple
from whole foods it's not trivial if you
ask me
but
i don't know i've always had this
feeling of like i've always kept myself
honest which is what i want is to have
uh you know a fat mansion and be eating
a feast with all the people my friends
and you know family like all at the
table we're laughing and joking that's
my ideal
but
what's even better than that what's even
better than having the sick mansion with
the feast with all your friends and
family all around you and you're
laughing at the great joke you just
cracked okay that's what i thought was
the peak but the actual peak of the peak
is you're the type person that you can
get stuck in an elevator and have fun
because then you're invincible what's
better than invincible mode it's like
you can put me in the shittiest
situation and i'm still gonna be
laughing okay so now what now i don't
really have anything to fear because my
my situation my my feelings weren't
dependent on having all those those
items all right even though i prefer
them so um
so yeah yeah i think that i guess like
yeah i do make some shifts in my like
lifestyle but it's not like to me i'm
like oh cool it's a new season like it's
tightening up season it's like you know
it's like getting shredded for the
summer for you know your body it's like
cool i'm also gonna go and cancel a
bunch of subscriptions i don't care
about because it'll make me feel good
like i'm i'm i'm putting a healthy
amount of discipline in like i kind of
accrued a bunch of excess fat when it
was one season and now it's time to
cleanse and like good like you know
where where am i spending that i don't
really want to be spending you know
where are we where are we advertising
that's inefficient you know who's on our
payroll that's not really pulling their
weight good let's get rid of all that
weight now is it spring cleaning baby
right so it's like that's the next step
for me is like you do an actual spring
cleaning and be excited about it i've
been using truebill this is not an ad
but have you seen it yeah it's called
truebill i bought like the 100
subscription have you ever used that
you know what that hasn't used it but
i've used stuff like it yeah it
basically like looks at your
subscriptions and like suggests how does
it know what you're not using it
suggests what to cut right
yeah like drives them
like i didn't realize that me and sarah
both had amazon prime subscriptions like
apparently i thought i cancelled one of
them and so it catches that and it also
like i just see how much i'm spending
every month and i'll say you have an
upcoming 300
subscription coming up and it's like oh
that's my trainer um but there's been
times where i'm like oh damn i thought i
didn't know i had xbox live or whatever
the hell that thing's called uh it's a
29 thing and it's coming up and so you
can like cancel it but then what they do
is
if you need to cancel something that you
want to call
they'll like do it for you they'll do it
for you
it's pretty cool um yeah and so so
that's another piece of this which is uh
me me ben and saffon we were hanging out
this morning and so we you know we all
hung out together and we're getting our
coffee for that's the milk team and
we're like or like part of it and we
were like okay let's just make a real
list real quick let's assume for a
second
assume this market condition these
market conditions last for the next
let's call it 18 months so let's assume
the stock market yeah it'll bounce back
from like whatever it'll find some low
and it'll
bounce back a little bit but it's not
going to be like
all right baby we're back to every you
know everything just keeps going up
we're all printing money right that's
not going to happen let's say for for
the next cycle
um same thing with crypto let's say that
you know companies you know they're not
giving out raises or hiring as much
let's say that customers tighten up
their spending so revenues go down
across the board like cool let's assume
all that to be true
do we also believe that like like first
some things are going to die some things
are going to survive and some things are
going to thrive true bill is something
that thrives
during a time like this right because
it's helping you
bring some you know austerity or like
you know uh financial discipline into
your life so people are going to want
that product more so they're going to
thrive what else is going to thrive
maybe short sellers are going to thrive
right now because they've been betting
that the market's gonna go down and sure
enough it has who else is gonna thrive
you know the guy who's been sitting on a
bunch of cash on the sidelines is like
oh actually like
there's things that i think are valuable
businesses like you know facebook and
amazon that are trading at all times
sort of like you know lows in the last
decade like now is the time to dollar
cost average into these companies
dude how about assets how about moist
saying he had in the interview you did
with him saying he had 50 million in
cash and he was like i just him waiting
it's like oh okay now uh
yeah i understand what you want
yeah
yeah exactly i remember uh just as like
a small anecdote like i remember maybe
seven years ago six years ago something
like that i don't know i bought bitcoin
for the first i think i bought 10 grand
of bitcoin back when bitcoin was like at
600 700 it's like 700 bucks
and the next week it goes up to 800 and
i'm like there we go baby just as i
wanted buy the thing price goes up love
it when they stick to the script
and uh like i think two weeks later or
something like that i don't remember
making up timelines here but very short
soon after that bitcoin crashed to like
200 so my like what was 800 was now you
know i lost you know whatever 75 i don't
know public math but you get the idea
lost a bunch of money in that process
and at that time 10 000 like i was
making
150k a year i think was like my salary
actually definitely i made it either 120
or 160. so i i remember when that was
and i remember you told me you made 150
grand a year in salary and i was like
oh my god you're the richest person i
know
yeah i was the person i knew at that
time so i was like and you know and
actually like in reality i was underpaid
for you know what i was doing but in my
head i was i was like wow don't say
anything they might realize how much
money they're paying you you know like
that was like i was so honored to be
making that kind of money so um and like
i feel good that i was honored like it
feels it's it's great to feel honored at
what you're getting that's actually an
awesome feeling to be in versus
consistently dissatisfied um but like i
remember it went down to 200 i walked
into the office and i was like bitching
about the like the crash of i was like
my bitcoin because like you know i'm
very public when i invest in things
which makes me often look like a dummy
but occasionally it makes me look very
smart and i was like oh guys my bitcoin
purchases
my my i forgot to put it 10 or 20 grand
something like that i was like it's uh
it's like all gone now and furcon was
like um he's like this is great right
like
you know do like do you believe less
than bitcoin just like than you did two
weeks ago like did you learn some new
information
like besides the price changing like did
you learn any new information bitcoin
that makes you less bullish on bitcoin i
was like no
like barely knew anything to begin with
and like you know nothing changed and
he's like cool so like if you bought now
you could bring your average cost basis
down to like
and i was like
oh like yes that's true and i went home
and i did it and i was like i like i
remember going from like just what i
thought was the only response i thought
the only response is [__] and moan and
then he kind of pointed out well like
did your actual conviction change or
just the valuation i was like right well
i don't know my conviction didn't change
not to say i had a ton of like very well
thought through conviction at the time
but like it didn't change and so i did i
lowered my cost basis to 400. now as
bitcoin bitcoin today trading like i
don't know twenty three hundred twenty
two thousand something like that but
like let's say on the average last year
it's been like 30k
so that that's the difference between
basically like an 8x and a 4x in your
return was that one conversation during
that one time and i've heard this many
many times before which is like you know
fortunes are built during these bear
market times and it's really for two
reasons number one
if you start a company
you're gonna be like the lean mean
cockroach you're not gonna have too much
competition and you're going to build up
your cons your kind of team and consumer
base now
um so that as you know
as the tide lifts all the boats you're
the biggest [__] boat that's what
happened to you with the hustle and like
that's what happened to many companies
that started during you know let's say
the
recessions or bear markets the same
thing happens with investing it's like
well
the goal
if your strategy with investing is to
only buy in when things are going up
and then like sell or do nothing when
prices go down like you have
inadvertently subscribed to a buy high
sell low strategy
and like you know i think we know that
that's not a winning strategy and so
like
um
you know well then what's the opposite
of that the opposite of that is to
if you have conviction or if there are
good assets that are underpriced
temporarily like there's a dislocation
because of panic and fear like those are
the times where you're supposed to buy
in it's very hard to do so because your
mentality is like like i just lost a ton
of money i don't feel like going and
putting more at risk but
in reality we kind of know that is the
right thing to do
for the if you can pick assets properly
dude what i've been learning about this
and i tweeted this out was like
i'd rather just earn more income and
build more companies than worry about
these losses
um so
let me can i
let's let's shift a little bit can i
tell you about a company or this uh you
remember how you said i find these
things that are kind of interesting and
weird i found another one
and i want to tell you about it
all right
have you heard of this conference called
shop talk
shop talk no
name sounds familiar one second let me
go to this so start to describe it let
me see if i have heard of this all right
so it's a conference that i think you
would have been involved in because it's
for e-commerce people but it's not just
like it's not like d2c entrepreneurs
it's like shopify as well as like every
shopify plug-in as well as like uh
retail brands like like the founder of
or the ceo of j crew might go and talk
to like the see talk on a panel with
like
the someone at stripe i don't know just
like it's like online commerce but like
for retail stuff does that make sense
but it's like sorry give me the use case
so who who goes i'm uh i'm an e-com
store so should i go to this
uh
probably not but if you're like you
would go and speak and like executives
at gaap would be like oh like these
young startups here's what they're doing
maybe we should like consider changing
our strategy to x y and z or we're we're
making apps for this we're making
software for this ecosystem let's go and
talk to other apps and maybe we could do
business together does that make sense
let me ask you slightly slightly
differently there's like kind of like
trade shows or like it's a trade
conferences where it's okay it's more
like a trade show gotcha it's a trade
show all right but here's where things
get interesting so the guy who started
it i linked uh to his uh his linkedin
down there uh in the document and i
think his name is jonathan weiner and he
has this co-founder he's an indian guy
named
i forget the indian guy's name but uh so
listen to their background and let me
tell you what they're doing now and why
this is so fascinating so i really
linked an article from vox and it said
the guys behind money 2020 conference
want to do the same thing but for
commerce so
what that's what that will explain is
basically this guy jonathan and his
partner they started a company by the
way i saw you smirk when i said the
guy's last name that was hilarious um
i was trying so hard to come up with a
good joke uh and i just
you know
my filter in my brain was like you know
what not worth the risk
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a task from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
so this guy and his partner uh jonathan
weiner is in his indian partner it's
like you and you and me like the wiener
and the brown guy
[Laughter]
so uh
this guy they had an ad tech company as
well as a payment software business that
they sold for hundreds of millions of
dollars and then oddly they went and
started a conference and it was called
money 2020 which was like a fintech
payment processors trade show business
and within two years
they scaled it to like 30 or 25 million
in revenue with 10 million in profit and
they sold it for 100 million dollars
right when they sold it they went and
started the same thing and they called
it shop talk and they did it for
commerce and they sold that for over 100
million dollars and they sold both money
2020 and shop talk to two different
publicly traded companies so all these
numbers that i'm saying um you can
actually go and look at the numbers and
like verify the acquisition price as
well as the revenue now
i noticed that one of the founders spun
off and he's doing a different thing
called like the fintech meetup or
something involving fintech and then the
other guy is doing one called health
it's
pronounced health it's spelled hlth.com
and he's doing this a trade show
business for healthcare and they're
basically doing the same strategy every
single time and if you go to all three
of their of their conference websites
and you click the about page they have
these really cool cartoons about uh
cartoons instead of like headshots of
each employee they just do cartoons
they've done that for every single about
page so they're more likely than not
like hiring like the same people the
same graphic designers
because they're not
yeah they're non-compete probably says
like look you can't create anything in
the fintech space anymore you can't
create a thing in the commerce space
anymore and they're like all right let's
do health let's do this let's do that
and it's so interesting that they're
getting into conference and trade show
businesses as opposed to software and
they've crushed it they are crushing it
and they don't raise money and they just
like it's like every three years they
start something and sell it for 100
million dollars and it's the same thing
and they've done it two or three times
now isn't that crazy
this is amazing that you've done it
again sam you have done it again dude i
love these in fact i remember you
telling me about money 20 20 a little
while back because you've always been
interested in conferences trade shows
businesses from the hustle con days
and uh i remember every time you told me
about these i was like
sort of consistently blown away as to
how much money these make um
now what do you think is the playbook to
do this because like for example well
this is kind of in transparency we've
talked about this with the milk road of
like dude there's a lot of like
there's a lot of money and there's a lot
of moving parts to like people who are
you know have some interest in this
whether it's like wall street people
kind of want to get educated on this
stuff uh you know
insurance you know let's call it like
mutual funds hedge funds bankers
whatever and then there's like crypto
people there's vcs like all these
different people who are like
professionals
and there are tons of conferences right
so it's not like some uncompetitive
space
but what are these guys doing that's
better or different because i don't
believe most conferences businesses are
scaling this fast or selling for this
much so what are the what's this guy
what are their what's their playbook
compared to how most people do it do you
know
a little bit so the misconception with a
lot of these make some conjectures make
some guesses because of course yeah
exactly and i've tried to like
deconstruct it just based on the outside
but so the misconception about
conferences is that you need cool
speakers and people come to watch
content and as i've studied these guys
and read their quotes and figure out
exactly how they do it and i ran a
conference business that made millions
of dollars a year i've realized that the
real money like the 20 30 40 million a
year money it's not necessarily a
conference it's a three-day
transactional event it's you you're
creating ebay or you're creating a main
street with stores on the on the street
and renting it out you're creating that
but it just so happens that's going to
happen in three days so years where the
business is going to happen in three
days and so what you have to think about
is your
your speakers are just the bait to get
the right people to come and then once a
certain right people are coming the rest
of the right people will come and
they're justifying all of it in the
they're justifying all of it by a couple
things the first thing
they're justifying it because they say
[__] our competitor is there we have to
be there so that's like a really big
thing and so i've talked to my friend um
uh who runs block works that other
crypto media site and they have this
huge crypto business and he was like man
it's pretty crazy like if blank
companies coming other company is like
oh we gotta come and can we like get a
better booth than them and so that's
like a really common thing but the
second thing and more logical thing is
all right look if we're gonna buy this
hundred thousand dollar booth we got to
close all these deals who's you know
what shot callers are going to be there
and we have to do a really good job of
making transactions happen so that's the
really big thing is you have to realize
that this so there's this guy named
sheldon adelson do you know who that is
yeah he's like the
vegas casino uh guy right or is that his
cousin yeah he's a mean as [__] old
billionaire he's like known for being
like a huge [__] and he's worth like
20 or 40 billion dollars
looking guy
yeah like he's like looks like this and
he like thinks that like weed is like
the end of the world and so he like buys
uh all these ads about how like wheat is
you remember like uh those commercials
like julie used to care about stuff now
she just smokes weed all day and you
know like it's like it's like someone's
like this is your egg this is your egg
this is your brain on weed and it's like
cracks in it yeah it was it was like
it was like
they used to have these commercials with
like someone like melting into the couch
and they're like she used to go for runs
all the time now she just sits and watch
tv it's like anyway he's like a huge
anti-weed guy and so but he's just like
90 year old guy i think i forget what he
owns but it's like the largest he
basically this guy definitely just had
like a bad weed experience he like
definitely smoked weed in college and
like peter's pants got made fun of ford
like there's got to be some deep rooted
like i've looked at hospitals
what is it so it is serious his kid i
think became a drug addict and he like
thought and this guy like grouped weed
and into the same as all that other
[__] which is not which i think is
crazy but he basically started uh this
event called comdex which eventually was
acquired for a billion dollars by
softbank and it be and it became uh
what's that thing the consumer
electronic ces and i read i would read
all these old articles about him and he
goes you know you're in the conference
business and now you're in the real
estate business building up las vegas
strip what are you doing and he goes
well the conference business is the real
estate business what i learned early on
was i got to get people and foot traffic
to my event and then i'm just selling
real estate at a crazy high square
footage and uh it's the same thing and
so that's why i'm into real estate now
and he basically built up all these
hotels i forget all the casinos he owns
there's like three big vegas casinos and
he owns one of the biggest one and uh
anyway so these events are rooted in
like real estate and foot traffic and so
that's really how you do it the second
thing is it's got to be b2b of course a
[__] ted talk is like the coolest
thing out there but like
you know
people coming to like hear talk about
why sleep matters or like how to cure
malaria that's unfortunately not where
the money is if your name is anything
but ted so if you're anyone else but ted
don't do these like sexy things do
boring ass b2b we're here to get some
deals done and we're going to sell you
some [__] you know it's a bunch of a
bunch of white dudes with uh tight blue
jeans and like those brown leather shoes
and tucked in collar shirts just like
you know sales bros that's what that's
like where the money is
at least 40 of participants must have a
tucked in
button-up shirt uh or polo
and uh you know like half the jokes need
to be about their wife uh you know like
something something complaining about
their wife and then uh like if you said
the old ball and chain you'd get like a
default smirk from anybody you know like
their badge needs to be like you know
semi tucked in under the belly like
that's who you need at these conferences
for this to work
yeah and if you don't have a tucker in
your crew you're out you're just you're
not part of this you have to have a
tucker in your crew
right so there's like a dog like a bomb
sniffing dog that's just looking for
tuckers in line yeah there's not enough
tuckers in this in this queue shut it
down
yeah
so that's what is the german shepherd
that's that's where it seems the money
is um is like joining these uh
industries that are fast growing and
making it a a real estate you thinking
like a real estate person
and how do you um how do they go get
people to go buy these tickets so like
i'm assuming they're basically selling
or is their model you sell tickets for a
couple thousand each and then you sell
sponsor booths for you know tens of
thousands each something like that um is
that the model
i think what they do so i went and
looked at their revenue and so their
revenue in year one is like two or three
million and then in year two it's like
12 and then you're three it's like 30.
so based off of that and it's a bunch of
marketing materials and as well as their
head count on their about page i think
what they do
is they just give away a bunch in the
first year in the first year you're just
trying not to lose your shirt um and i
also think that they when they sell
sponsorships
which are actually
can be easier to sell for these things
they like only give away x amount of
tickets and for the rest of the people
to come you have to purchase it and once
you get a certain
amount of sponsors it's kind of like we
used to host we used to host events and
we would purposely have like as many
speakers as possible because each
speaker would bring like 10 people and
so i think it's kind of like that where
each sponsored company automatically
brings a small crew
and that is how they actually do it and
because they don't
they spend a lot in marketing though and
they have based on their teams they have
it's like that you know that spider-man
meme the spider-man maybe they're all
pointing at each other like yeah yeah
spider-man it's that but just sponsors
at the booth being like buy my stuff buy
my thing no buy like you buy my thing
i'm here to sell not to buy
yeah it's a circular economy of just
like you know buying buying one
another's crap um but uh anyway it's
kind of cool what they're doing and
i think
this business i think events can be a
headache but
there's a way that you can build it
what
what i would do by the way if i was
international i would study these guys
and i would do the exact same thing in
europe then i would do the exact same
thing in australia i would do the exact
same thing in india and in china and in
south africa like wherever you are there
is a version of this that can be built
locally that is not going to be
competitive with these basically like
this is a clonable template in my
opinion i'm sure it takes good execution
i'm not saying that but i think this is
a business that can like generically
work in other markets and either they're
converting schools or other countries
there can be more than one winner you
know like you can go to more than one
conference a year and so it it's not a
winner take all business so it's kind of
interesting and interestingly all the
companies that have bought these guys as
companies have been european and i
looked online about what they were doing
and
one of the big things that they were
doing was first of all they've gotten
really good at selling so they host the
event in 2022 and at the end of 2022
they already have uh 90 of the revenue
for 2023 because you sell the you upsell
the people like right away for the next
year and you can sell multiple years
you're back for now the second thing
that they're doing is they're starting
to charge money for online communities
so like all right you met at the
conference you can keep this up and like
and so they're doing online communities
and that's one of the reasons that's the
business one of the business i'm
interested in and that's why i've been
studying this and figuring this out it's
just this is a super fascinating thing i
think
it is this is great i i really like this
one um anything else on this otherwise
we could do another
topic no i don't i [__] i just so i
have i have so much stuff back loaded by
the way uh and i know i spent like half
of
40 minutes of this podcast just being
like
the mentality of a downturn but again i
think it's the most whether you're an
employee
you're a employer or you're an investor
like nobody is going to be spared from
the economy going into a recession the
stock market tanking in the crypto
markets tanking and global inflation
like this is like uh
you know like you like oprah comes out
and she's like you know you get a
disaster you get a disaster you get a
disaster to everybody right like nobody
is going to be untouched by the effects
of this some people are going to get hit
to the point where their business goes
under they declare bankruptcy personally
or in the business whatever that's going
to happen but i don't see anybody
getting untouched by like a
stack of problems like that
man when i remember when biden was
saying that putin was going to evade uh
invade ukraine and uh i was like reading
about putin and listening to ben's
podcast how to take over the world and i
was like
hey putin why do you
why do you want to [__] this up for
everyone like things are pretty awesome
right now like what are you thinking
like just i that that's just the
conversation i wanted to have like you
know like
putin like everything's pretty pretty
good what what what like you're gonna
blow this for everyone we're all gonna
get screwed
and that's like the conversation that
i've that's like the kid in class who's
the kid in class who raises his hand is
just like hey miss you forgot to collect
the homework and it's like
dude what are you doing
are you chilling we're seven minutes
away from getting out of here
dude do you buy okay so this is like
sounds like a very like uh yuppy [__]
thing to say but i don't really look at
gas prices because they don't drive that
much but you know it's just like it's i
gotta buy gas and it's not gonna hurt me
however much it costs i'll buy it and uh
i was driving up here from austin to
brooklyn where i'm living now and
i was
listening to the news they're talking
about gas prices and i was like oh [__]
i haven't even looked at the gas prices
while i've been driving up here i wonder
what it is and it was like 550 and it
was crazy again i know like what the
news was saying but i just wasn't
looking because i don't drive that much
what's the gas in california where you
are are you paying like
650 seven dollars a gallon how the [__]
are normal people
doing this
that is crazy that is crazy
seven dollars
yeah when you said 550 i was like wait
you're saying you found a good deal but
you were trying to say that's a bad deal
right
i thought that was real i mean i've
lived in california two years i remember
in california it was five dollars but
what is it in austin
dude i don't even know i just looked in
like west virginia when i was driving up
here i don't pay attention to the gas
prices i don't drive that much and i
just don't i'm buying it no matter what
it says
uh but like seven dollars how this is
we're selling [__] fools right now
how much gas does a car take i don't
even know like i mean it would cost like
150 dollars i guess to fill up like how
big is the tank yeah i drive an suv so
it's like you know 20 gallons basically
um
all right jonathan says it's about 450
austin
dude so you're spending 150 to get gas
yes
um
yeah it's bad but you know asking for a
friend you know like okay i got like a
you know
a car that says like you should use the
good you know pay the most when you go
to the gas station like pick the pick
the top of the the three options
um like let's just say what do you drive
what's your suv
i got a bmw uh x5 and so it's like let's
say your boy's been uh putting the
shitty one in for a while like you know
does this matter is this is this like
marketing or uh you know like do i pay
some price later in life or do i pay
some price now like i actually never
really knew how big of a deal that is
like is it pretty strict
i don't know i i but
you're paying
i don't know but i'm going to be honest
it doesn't sound great it doesn't sound
like that's what you want to be doing
to me i'm like you know is that this
seems like a recommendation not a rule
and uh you know so i've been going with
the 87 whatever that stands for instead
of the like 90 or whatever the the top
end gas is and i've just been like you
know okay so
the most expensive thing is like eating
mcdonald's
uh the most yeah i don't even know what
the yeah it's basically around seven
bucks uh seven bucks a gallon i think i
think that's kind of the top oh my god
or something
that's crazy yeah that's that's wild so
every 18 miles is seven dollars for you
basically
yeah i don't know i don't even think
about it like it is what it is i need to
get places and like that's the cost of
cash right now like what am i going to
do
i'm not going to drive to west virginia
and get gas
uh i'm not gonna not drive around you
know like i do need to go places and so
you know it is what it is
of course it's not a big deal for you
but
uh you remember how we were talking
we were talking about how the economy
was crushing for years and years and
i've got so many friends that they're
like man i've got i've been in in my
apartment for a year and a half for two
years i've got a money burning hole in
my pocket like i haven't bought anything
out i have i have all-time high savings
i'm ready to save and all these people
are quitting their jobs because they're
like f that like i get these checks i've
saved up money like i'm not taking this
thing
at seven dollars a gallon like people
are just gonna run out i guess right i
mean like you're just gonna run out of
savings
a huge amount of people again you
again you got to cut back right so you
know i cut back down to that low end gas
so i could you know save the 30 40 cents
a gallon other people are just gonna
drive less so they're gonna say public
transport or they're gonna carpool or
they're gonna find something like people
will find a way is you know my general
mentality and like
uh i don't know i spent a lot of my life
living in like
jakarta or like beijing and you just see
people like in beijing right next to our
house there's just people just shucking
corn like all day
they're just sitting in a squat just
like removing husks from corn
for like 10 hours straight in the heat
and they were just like you know and
then they would like take their break
smoke a cigarette and play some mahjong
and like you know like that's what they
did and they were fine and then like you
know your driver had different set of
problems and like in jakarta like in
india people just burn trash on the side
of the road because there's no like
waste removal thing so they're like you
burn it and then it's gone it's like
yeah but like it smells awful all day
and like what are you talking about this
is like how air smells i was like no no
man that's not how air has to smell but
like you know i don't know you the range
of how humans can live survive and
thrive is so much wider
than like you know the average person
thinks um
and so i don't know like
i don't know i just don't really pay too
much attention it's just like
you have to like i don't know
you just have to like kind of figure out
how to govern yourself in a new world
it's like are you a self-governing
individual or not because like if you
are not a self-governing individual
every day you're going to get punched in
the face with bad news right now and
like you got to learn how to parry a
punch otherwise you are going to get
like knocked out by just taking most
jabs to the nose every day
like i just got done i was in missouri
for two weeks most people aren't like
that they're just like
they're most people are not that
resourceful that's what i've i've
learned uh i i actually think that our
audience is like that most are not like
oh i gotta go start something i gotta do
this i gotta
i think most people will just
are just gonna be [__]
that's i mean that's really what i think
so so i'm writing a book right now i
don't know if i tell you this i write a
book i'm using that like scribe media
thing where you they like write the book
for you or whatever but is it all your
content they just
they write the words after you say it to
the guy on the fun for like two hours
every like week or something
uh i don't know if it's awesome i'm
loving doing it because i'm like oh cool
i get to like put something down on
paper like i don't know this is fun
um
and i'm not gonna like sell the book i'm
gonna do something different with it but
whatever so basically point is um the
start of my book is that um everybody
wants the same things like everybody
wants
to be like wealthy everybody wants to be
like in great relationships great family
and everybody wants to be like in you
know great shape
you look at like okay cool so like if
everybody wants that and that's all
achievable then certainly you know like
most people are doing that no okay half
people are it's like
most people have the exact opposite of
that result
most marriages are ending in you know
unhappy or ending a divorce most people
in america are you know overweight or
obese and most people don't have like
you know
uh
more than ten thousand dollars of
savings in the bank or whatever for like
a rainy day and so everybody wants the
same things everybody wants to be you
know uh you know
rich fit and madly in love and in fact
everybody has the opposite and so like
if
if you think like most people think
you're gonna do what most people do and
you're gonna get the result most people
get and the sad truth is that the
results most people are getting are not
very good and like i
so that's the start of my like that's
the premise of my book and um that's the
start and then the the the second part
of
i guess like i would say a controversial
thing about me is
um
i am totally okay not
taking into consideration
most people's situation
i am so like for example i always i i it
sounds like an [__] thing i
understand i said it
purposely provocative way right i did
not want to soften that
um what do i mean by that like i always
talked about like oh i love to teach and
i want to be a teacher
um so most people see that as like some
like mother teresa you know like sort of
like save the world like be the
educator who helps all i'm like no no i
do not want to try to educate everybody
or teach everybody i'm like most people
are horrible students they don't want to
learn anything they're not going to
learn anything they're not going to do
anything with even if you told them the
exact right answer or how to think
they're just not going to do it so like
why would i waste my energy doing that
like no no my preference is like in a in
a population of 100 of people there's
like three percent that like really want
to know the answer and of them maybe
like 20 of them are to be able to
actually take action on it i'm only
going to try to teach the driven and
motivated and capable like
and that is not a like society like
socially acceptable point of view
um but it is my like operating
philosophy is to like
uh myself i focus on the controlling the
things i can control and not other
things and secondly like even when i'm
like talking about what most people
should do
i know that most people are not going to
be able to do that or want to do that or
choose to do that that's okay i'm not
talking to most people i'm talking to
the one to three percent of the
population who like wants to thrive in
those ways and uh i hope everybody else
listens to it and says this guy's a jerk
and like does so out of touch it's like
and they leave uh they leave my orbit
and they unfollow me completely because
i'm like
uh
i am trying to be intentionally out of
touch in the same way that i
intentionally avoid the news
that's hilarious it is
part of my core strategy is to be out of
touch and avoid the news and like not
not not learn from or speak to the
common denominator of the population and
i i know that all of that sounds
completely awful to some people
and uh
but you know i'm okay with that like it
i i do believe even if you disagree with
that
i hope you agree that like i'm allowed
to have that choice to do that and if
you don't think i have the choice to do
that um like you know then i disagree
with you and all of your your ways of
living
yeah you're like if you
i get that if you don't if you don't
think that my opinion is good i get that
and you're fine but you're wrong and i
hate you that's basically no no what it
is
if you think my opinion is wrong
if you think my opinion's wrong uh i
understand and i i would expect that
from a lot of people
if you think i shouldn't be allowed to
have my opinion or to act on my opinion
that's where uh like there's a
difference between i disagree
and that's not allowed or that's not
okay
or no you can't do that or you know
lynch him you know like there's a
there's a difference in like being able
to disagree and disallow and i would say
you're you're you know like
a little far with the lynch yeah they're
gonna kill them
yeah lynch them yeah um yeah yeah that's
that's probably a bit bit harsh
all right that's the pod
we'll see if people uh dig it i uh dude
what if tomorrow it just goes back to
normal
that would be nice by the way if
if you want to cancel me i hope people
get our voices mixed up and this has
been sam talking that whole time
why this people issue here is sam
i think they're saying that p-a-r-r
you could find him he's a is affiliated
with hubspot if you want to go get them
like that's the guy to go get if you
didn't like what was just said
dude i still get people messaging me
saying that they
they they confuse us still
i don't understand that yeah i guess i
think people go watch the youtube video
and they're like [__] i've been had you
guys oppos mixed up for like a year
i i think what they're saying is i look
beefier but i talk nerdier and you look
nerdier and you talk beefier so
it is what it is you you look dumb and
you talk smart and i look smart and i
talk dumb
uh all right we'll talk soon peanut
butter and jelly baby it's a perfect
coffee yeah
[Music]
you